oder was geht ab ihr seid willkommen zu
einer runde crazy works lucky mode heute
in der not change mit jonas fischer ja
genau was geht ab weil jona na ja sage
ich ich bin hetero du bist ein lob aus
deswegen ist den du kennst du spielst
den spielen zum ersten mal ja wie soll
ich sagen auch sonst ist jona natürlich
ein echter pro und ich bin voll dabei
wird es schon wieder wir wollen einfach
mal so einen kleinen change machen weil
sie die oma wirklich noch nie dass das
game gespielt hatten deshalb schauen wir
kann der was kann das was werden im team
modus glaube es wird echt schwierig weil
man muss relativ stabilen teams spielen
um zu gewinnen bei dem spielmodus also
auch wenn ich halt wenn ich zwei poster
der provinz spielen sie nehmen bei mir
bist halt genau richtig
gerade in der runde davor wurde er dann
hättet sobald die world gefallen sind
ja weil ich habe keine erklärung ich
darf mir durch meine dunkel ist
unterm strich zähle ich und ich und ich
werde mir jetzt auch erstmal ein
scharfes schwert machen für den anfang
weil dann können wir direkt schon mal
relativ gut starten hoffe ich zumindest
und wenn du unten stehst ganz einfach
mit service an die oberfläche sich
teleportieren
ja das mache jetzt nämlich auch mal dann
kann ich noch schnell meine finalen
einkäufe züge abschließen und dann bin
ich mal gespannt wie ich mit dir an
meiner seite kämpfen kann ich gut
gerade auf der aus gut an porträt gerade
damit seien stärker 1 bogen das ist ja
mal richtig gehasst weil ich habe keine
feinde stärker einfach kacke hast du ein
paar pfeile als das ist zumindest nicht
kacke
hier hast du mir einen zurück und einen
heiltrank wächst wie mainz rücken
dankeschön ok grüne wand fällt jetzt
gold apfel auf wenn 22 sekunden ist rein
okay wir sind auch schon direkt
aggressiv die leute da drüben diesem
ziemlich guter club der einfach rein
pfeifen ja darüber ein bisschen
aufpassen woher du mich erfolg ich
sterbe ich sterbe ich sterbe ich sterbe
damit als willkommen zurück
damit ihr wisst was überhaupt gemeinsam
hinter einem loop change der ist zwar
gemeint und ich muss jetzt probieren
allein im bild durchzukämpfen
dennoch so dass die fall dass ich eine
vorahnung hätte dass du sterben würdest
oder so jung dass herrchen machen soll
die war voll gut ja die waren sehr gut
und du hast vollkommen recht
ok ich muss jetzt probieren die gegner
irgendwie aneinander vorbei zu hetzen
weil wenn der mich weiter chase sind sie
auch für mich schlecht aus du warst ein
verschwendung meines gold aktion an den
könnte ich jetzt gut gebrauchen
es tut mir leid sehr schön kämpfen
hätten wir haben zwar jetzt gegeben
laufen jetzt alle mir ja alle echt alle
boxer jetzt gegenseitig sehr schön
dann kann ich mir nämlich jetzt hier
einen privaten blog kaufen platzieren
hoffen dass ein gutes schwert rauskommt
und ja es ganz cool walter ich glaube
ich halte aber gleich erst dann kann ich
auf jeden fall ein bisschen rennen und
regenerieren und dann kann ich ein ganz
klein bisschen und dann wieder saniert
und rennen auf distanz kein bisschen
es war ja klar das ist schon so ein
special schwerer sonic oder ach verdammt
ich wollte sagen warum warum team die
aber wir sind ein team runde und nur
mein team aids gestorben sind natürlich
sehr schlecht für adwords von jona das
ist eine hardcore challenge so ne runde
allein zu bestreiten ist kein
zuckerschlecken würde ich mal sagen das
projekt durchaus wie gene die auch
irgendwie gar nicht geführt weiter jetzt
muss ich ein bisschen
die zunahme der 24 herzen von unten
wegzukommen und irgendwie war das war
richtig gut und böse richtig gut und da
und perfekter tag
das war ich will mir selbst loben aber
das war gut was ihn schön darum gerne
recht schlau sich von unten dran zu
bauen so dass medizin können sodann gar
nicht wie man diesen block gut immerhin
jona warum muss mich alleine gelassen
es ist ein team halt da vorn ich hab
keinen bock hat einfach was auf uns
zukommt verdammt ich brenne
ach mist kommt community
ich habe zumindest ein paar blocks
geklaut habe ich aber was ist das was
ist das hier was hier nicht oder falsch
ist schon mal gut bitte bist du gelegt
wenn ich mich aber dass er auf dem
server brauchst du dich nicht na also
die leute sind hier überwiegend
amerikanisch glaube jetzt kennt ihr
vielleicht vornherein und bisschen was
reißen ruhe sorgen
als session hatte caffier hat erst mal
selbst obwohl dir bitte sagen wenn
jemand kommt ich scheiß vollkommen auf
kosten jetzt okay weil ich bin gerade
echt sehr ich über den verlauf aber wenn
ich das reißen würde würde ich mich bis
an mein lebensende feiern kommt also
niemand jungen jetzt doch was war das
denn alles hat den bogen
so sei das problem wenn du alleine bist
hast du erst recht keine zeit oder keine
keine wirkliche chance sich
vorzubereiten
ich halte ich habe ein eigener vor
langweile sitzen also können kann ein
wenig so mega viel anrichten mit seiner
augen und ich werde am besten einfach
probieren wir den boden vor dem zu holen
alter der typ ist offen
wenn er auch noch so gutes schwert hat
dann bin ich halt echt hardcore am arsch
und hat ein gut fertig werden nicht so
wie ich jetzt gelernt bei mir papa ich
weiß es nicht
junge junge junge aber den kann sie
eigentlich kriegen voran obwohl er tritt
mir übel sein
wir haben gleich gleich viel erlebt ich
war konnte
du bist du bist du ist auch wurscht
eigentlich bin ich nicht so laut dass
ich das stück sind nach drei drin
das heißt ich bin schon mal recht weit
gekommen ja auf jeden fall aufs
treppchen geschafft
danke dir auf arendts support auf jeden
fall jona
ja ich habe 13 schwert ist am start und
noch jede menge spielzeug
ich weiß nicht ob das was werden kann
alter einerseits habe ich echt gutes
zeug
andererseits leute der ender drache
macht hier noch die medcup musste gar
nicht das was kommt
der club steckt ja ja hab ich gesehen
hab ihn papi und ich glücklich objekt
als alter hat mich übelst weg richtig
cool sein problem war dass er eine
spitzhacke handkraft sonst hätte mich
halt voll basiert aber sowieso wieder
mit chris gegeben hat alter wenn ich
fragen nicht zu garantieren können
strings okay da schießt mit dem mit dem
sprosse vor es sollte besser
falten alter wusste typ okay dann ist
eine tradition
euro
danke ändert rache der pegel einfach den
weg gen gebaut eine chance zu haben
tnt gibt sie noch irgendwo billiger
weißt du was ist da würde ich sagen okay
ja ja eh sie da nicht die 7
mein gott oh mein gott ich habe mit kies
gemacht und glaubt nicht ich hätte gar
8000 ist richtig klasse runde
ich hab's nicht fallen bist du nicht mal
macht eine runde der extravaganz